no sugar to understand do you need some
more hmm oh my gosh hmm do you need more
no I have no idea what Spain ecology is
I mean if you want to try to study the
average China hours yes bank and then
Paulo geology is the study of that's my
I might be right about that cut it if
I'm wrong ecology is the study of it's
the study of spank spanking using
spanking the facts of spanking on the
psychology human behavior
yeah that's great exactly so you growing
up you were never spanked yes yes as I
was saying I was never spanked I don't
know how I will respond I was spanked
almost three times with a girl right now
you're a bad girl
I may cry here yeah it may get really
drag I'm getting spanked because I am a
bad girl who eats too much sugar so I'm
hoping that through this spanking I will
be better able to quit or at least
lessen my addiction to sugar I turn into
a procrastinator I don't know that was
not my case at all I was not a
procrastinator I want to stop it before
it turns into a bigger problem I mean
you know how many problems I can just
tackle yeah fix my life that's very Bank
at a time I don't care why you do
something I just want you to stop it
spanking is really about being held
accountable for things that you've done
wrong it's to change behavior and they
like the endorphin rush they need the
motivation every so often it is not BDSM
it is not pain for pain sake this is the
same sort of spanking that your mother
would have given you when someone
full-stop says it's not acceptable you
need to fix your behavior that is really
frightening to hear as an adult it
really goes right down to your core and
you're thinking oh my god wait no I need
to get out of
somehow but you can't and that's the
point if something traumatic happens it
forms a puts a groove in the brain what
I'm doing is the same thing but it's not
trauma to injure most of this is
psychology and then the spanking just
sort of underscores that alright Sarah
you're ready to get spanked I I guess I
have to be the first and foremost
implement that I use its my hands I
believe in bare hand to bare bottom
discipline so that when you're talking
you're spanking and they get the message
cane okay nice meeting you tell me in
your own words once again about like the
sugar recently I've been kind of turning
into this procrastinator we have so much
candy here and just like eating candy or
like soda so you can't go to the news
anymore focusing on that so that you'll
be disciplined enough to stay away anger
can make us stuck and that can have them
with anybody it's kind of giving you
some lethargy and it all boils down to
lack of discipline you cannot always be
in control sometimes you have to let go
so what I have your be motivated you
know how to walk around understand
hmm I give you a little bit of a
spanking a little bit the reason is not
because you're bad
okay but you must get it into your mind
that you must stay motivated I'm gonna
spank you a little bit I know all right
is that clear it's clear is it is it
this this is my first time this is the
first time you've been spanked yes
all right well better late than never
over my knee over my knee doing this for
your own own good understand no more
sugar hmm what I want you to do get
motivated to understand no sugar no
sugar got it yes yes ma'am oh oh oh this
hurts it but feels like really hot
you're very clear like there's a little
bit more clear to now yeah
oh my god forget I keep puncture Yoga
anything this cures anything
[Music]
that's the candy I'm not eating it thank
you for the spanking
so the spanking happened yesterday I was
feeling ashamed and shocked about the
spanking and the speech and today it's
my motivation when I go near Kent I'm
probably going to imagine her Stern
expression and disappointment in me if I
were to get the candy so makes me think
that we all need a symbolic or physical
spanking I think she was saying that
like you need to quit this isn't good
for you these are all things I already
know but sometimes just hearing someone
else say it to you and say it to you so
directly is very helpful so this morning
I woke up super early and began reading
my books get early to work that is
progress
I guess it's working thank you mom and
dad for not spanking me I can't tell you
if the timeouts worked but I don't know
pick your poison
[Music]